many of you are not going to believe what
I'm going to tell you today unless you've
actually been following the story, in which
case you will absolutely believe it.
Youtube d monetize that.
75% of our video clips that we uploaded yesterday
from yesterday's program, yesterday's show
that we did for you, which we spent all day
producing of course in filming and editing
and all of that stuff contained eight separate
clips that we uploaded to youtube and upon
uploading them, six of the eight or 75% were
instantly demonetized by youtube algorithms.
75% of the work we did yesterday, the content
that we spent all day producing was in a fraction
of a second deemed not advertisers friendly
and thus unable to earn any revenue for us
on Youtube.
So I want to be really clear here about what
I am saying and about what I'm not saying.
I'm not saying that we have a legal issue
on our hands here.
Let me be clear.
I'm not saying youtube can't choose to monetize
or not to monetize whatever they want, but
let me also be clear that we're playing by
the rules.
And this is not how the system is supposed
to work.
We don't do profanity on our channel.
We don't do violent and gory images.
We don't harass people on the basis of their
sexual orientation or other characteristics.
We don't bully people.
We don't dox people or anything like that.
We produce FCC safe, Progressive News and
commentary.
And while we're supposedly playing by all
of youtube rules, more and more of our content
is being demonetized.
So yesterday we produced the show.
We paid salaries to our staff, we paid studio
rent, we paid utilities, we paid connectivity,
we paid health insurance.
But the clips, 75% of them make no money on
youtube, hundreds of thousands of views yesterday
from these clips that make no money on youtube.
So this is a systemic issue and notice be,
I don't want to be misquoted.
There are articles that now are, there are
media outlets following my coverage of what's
going on on Youtube and they have started
to misquote what I am saying.
I am not saying we are being demonetized for
being left wing or progressive.
Okay.
The right has preached sob stories for years
about the anti right wing bias on Youtube
and everywhere else.
I am not saying this is anti left wing bias.
The evidence that I've found is that this
is an independent bias and pro corporate bias
within the news and politics space on Youtube.
So I think I just have to kind of get real
with you here about the situation.
I had to reach out to our partners, uh, this
week and basically say this may be resolved.
Okay.
This may simply be the new normal and we need
to kind of reposition our expectations around
the reality that this may never be fixed because
again, I don't think youtube believes anything
is broken.
I don't believe Youtube thinks there is anything
to fix here.
This is the system they want because it's
safe for them because their advertisers like
it.
There's also what appears to be a growing
issue of people being unsubscribed from our
channel and others that are independent news
and politics, and I am seeing this in the
analytics.
I've received hundreds of emails from people
who say, David, I've been a subscriber for
a month.
I've been a subscriber for a year.
I've been a subscriber for five years to your
youtube channel.
I went to your channel today because I didn't
notice any of your videos on my homepage and
I noticed that the subscribe button was enabled,
meaning I was able to click subscribe because
I had somehow been unsubscribed from your
channel.
Now I know a lot of people are going to hear
me say this and they'll email me and say,
David, this is happening to me as well.
I've already told you two about it.
I've told them about it 10 times.
All I can say is make sure you're subscribed
right now.
I mean check right now.
If you're watching on youtube and click the
subscribe button if you aren't, if you're
listening on the radio or to the podcast or
whatever, consider going to youtube and subscribing
to our channel there as well.
So I'm exploring many other options to try
to deal with this.
Uh, an issue that we're experiencing the most
direct is not, you know, moving our content
to some platform with no audience.
Sadly, I know people email me, they say, David,
start uploading to x, Y, or z website, moving
our content to websites where the content
isn't monetized and there's nobody watching
is not a solution to the problem.
Okay.
So what's important to understand is if we
didn't have any other revenue sources, we
might be in a position to have to change our
story choices in order to save our revenue.
And what I mean by that is if we didn't have
revenue coming in through membership or through
Patrion, I might have to start each day thinking,
okay, here's the six stories I want to do.
But four of those are likely not to make any
money on youtube.
I guess I'll pick some different stories.
I would never want to do that.
That is the death of independent media.
The whole point here is we cover what we believe
to be important and this is how these monetization
algorithms set the agenda and drive the narrative
by making certain content financially unsustainable.
So that's the freedom that we get when people
support us directly and as more and more people
contribute via direct membership and Patrion,
you are basically buying us a little sliver
of immunity from having to even think about
making decisions.
Like here's the stories I want to cover, but
they're not going to make any money.
Maybe I'll pick some stories that youtube
is algorithm would find to be brand safe.
I can't afford to spend all day researching
and filming and editing and having our staff
do that and pay salaries and health insurance
and rent only to lose out on the monetization.
So as I've said it before, I'll say it again.
The way to fix this is simply to fund the
shows you like directly.
Okay?
Become a member, www.joinpacman.com it's really
cheap.
It's really quick.
You get cool stuff, but you buy us immunity
from this disastrous situation that's taking
place.
There is a discount code for membership.
This is 2020 which will save you 40% a if
you want to do something else, you can go
to patrion.com/david Pakman show, especially
if you already are giving to other producers
on Patrion.
Throw us a dollar a month, throw us $2 a month.
It really does make a difference.
patrion.com/david Pakman show